area joe mohler he's over at wahl
burgers and joe we actually have a set
of binoculars up here so we just took a
bird's eye view down at your location as
you guys are bringing us a live shot
from wahlberg's have you had a burger
yet
i have not had a burger it's almost
almost my break time and i'll get it
then but you just mentioned you can see
us here at wall burgers on the roof and
i can actually see you guys way up there
on cosmo but take a look around here
it's friday night draft day two here on
the strip but all these people having a
great time a lot of people wearing their
jerseys a lot of people i'm just having
a great time uh the stages are right
across the street the red carpet stage
from where we are at here at wahlburgers
and a lot of people have been going to
the experience as well which is as you
know at the end of the link there a lot
of people just having a lot of fun and
as you could tell i'm wearing a
official draft t-shirt and i actually
just got a second one because we just
went shopping and i think it's pretty
great that you can come down here and
there's a number of nfl pop-up shops
actually
throughout the strip here and also the
experience where you can buy shirts just
like this and the official nfl shop the
only official one actually in the
country is in caesars palace at the
forum shop so you definitely have to
check that out and come down here and
get some shirts to remember this iconic
event i'll send it back to you guys
there at the cosmo